The Guardian has published a bombshell
report that former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort met personally
with the founder of WikiLeaks Julian
Assange at the Ecuadorian Embassy in
London WikiLeaks is refuting this story
in the strongest possible terms they're
saying that they're willing to bet 1
million dollars and Julian Assange as
head that man afford and Assange never
met the trouble is in this situation
there are a lot of liars saying a lot of
things we will try to untangle whether
or not Donald Trump colluded with the
Russians then the good news good news is
that a Virginia High School has made
students recite the Pledge of Allegiance
the bad news is they're making them
recited in Spanish we will investigate
the meaning of inclusiveness finally
vegans ruin a nice steak dinner and a
mother is trying to castrate her son in
the name of transgenderism I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
this is the most complicated news day
that we have had in weeks there is
breaking news for the first time the
Muller investigation might become
somewhat relevant with these charges
that the Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort met with WikiLeaks founder
Julian Assange you'll remember WikiLeaks
is the group that released all of the
hit the Hillary emails the DNC emails
this could be huge or it's a total lie
we will investigate what we know buckle
up of course they give me the most
difficult news day while I'm on the road
from my boudoir here in Tallahassee
Florida because I'll be giving a speech
tonight before we get to any of that
let's make a little money with movement
watches oh my gosh holiday season well
we've had the first holiday we had
Thanksgiving now people are getting
ready I think Hanukkah is next week or
this week i christmas is coming right
around the corner week Boxing Day that's
when you go get even more discounts get
a movement watch I love movement watches
I am both a obviously they sponsor the
show I also buy their products regularly
and I'm giving them at to my friends and
relatives for Christmas they are
fabulous they look super sharp this is
the revolver collection and looks very
cool and I get compliments on it all the
time
they have a new watch which is a
mechanical watch it's automatic it's a
little bit more expensive and it's
really really nice you would be paying a
ton of money for these watches and
stores four hundred five hundred bucks
for that mechanical watch who knows a
thousand dollars but movement is able to
cut out the middleman I love their
products they are all about looking good
while keeping it simple it's also ground
up entrepreneurs story it's these
college dropouts they now sell watches
they've sold almost two million in over
160 countries quality of design at a
fair price I can't say enough about this
organization they make just terrific
products get 25% off today during
movements Black Friday Cyber Monday sale
free shipping free returns by going to
MVM t.com slash cough fa c OV e fe fe do
it now you'll regret it if you miss this
sale your friends will love it MVM
t-dot-com / co f fa co v fe fe join the
movement I'm already doing it I'm giving
I'm giving out a bunch of these for for
Christmas they're just super super cool
and a great deal okay let's dig in
the toughest news day of the last few
months very very complicated story we're
gonna boil it down and tell you
everything you need to know right now
Bob Muller is going after Paul Manafort
Paul Manafort you'll remember got a plea
deal with the special counsel Bob Muller
Muller is right now saying that deal is
null and void that mana Ford lied to
this special council that his guilty
plea is going to remain but that he is
not getting any special protections
right now president Trump is going after
Muller and the Moller investigation
WikiLeaks is making million-dollar bets
what do we know so far about Paul
Manafort Paul Manafort right now is
rotting away in prison in solitary
confinement in Alexandria Virginia Paul
Manafort he's I've been a lobbyist for a
long time he's worked for major
Republican politicians on major
campaigns he you know did some dodgy
dealings as lobbyists or want to do and
he for a short period of time ran the
Trump campaign right around the
Republican nominating convention because
he was really good at whipping those
delegates Paul Manafort for that crime
and you know obviously other charges
but basically practically for that crime
is now rotting away in solitary
confinement in prison he ro or won't we
all safer now are we all safer that Paul
Manafort is off the streets we were
talking about criminal justice reform
how we need to get people out of prisons
they've locked up a guy basically for
helping Donald Trump Bob Muller right
now the special counsel is saying that
in his plea deal Paul Manafort lied and
breached the deal that he signed two
months ago Paul Manafort denies this in
the strongest terms he says he did not
lie to the special counsel what this
means is that all of those promises that
the special counsel made to Paul
Manafort that he could avoid certain
prison time for certain crimes he could
avoid going to jail for certain crimes
that's gone that is off the table now
but oh the way a plea deal works is you
say I'm gonna plead guilty to certain
crimes and you're gonna give me lenient
treatment the trouble now is he's not
going to receive any lenient treatment
but he can't withdraw his guilty plea so
he's already on the hook for those
crimes he faces 10 years in prison
currently and who knows with the
addition of other charges how much
longer he's going to be in prison what
was the lie about so what it seems to me
we're only getting little bits and
pieces of this is from this Guardian
story The Guardian ran it and they are
alleging that Paul Manafort met with
Julian Assange the head of WikiLeaks
multiple times over the years starting
in 2013 again in 2015 and then most
importantly in 2016 just before or right
around the time of the release of those
Democrat emails that had been hacked
that WikiLeaks sent out which certainly
changed the tenor of the presidential
election I don't know that Hillary would
have lost or rather that Hillary would
have won if these emails hadn't been
released I'm not sure about that Hillary
is a terrible candidate Trump ran a
unique campaign he's a unique American
figure but that's what the Democrats
blame it all on so the Guardian ran with
this story and all these parties that
are involved Paul Manafort and WikiLeaks
are denying now who knows Paul Manta
forts of lobbyists could he be a liar
sure Julian Assange is an anti-american
spy though he did help us out with that
Hillary Clinton election could he be
lying yeah of course he could but who
are the sources on the Guardian story
they're anonymous they're anonymous
manna forts calling them 100% false and
WikiLeaks is going really hard after
this they say that they will bet 1
million dollars and Julian Assange his
head that Paul Manafort and Julian
Assange never met so where would they
have met Julian Assange has been seeking
he's had a Cylon basically in the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London he's wanted
by many governments including the United
States for stealing their materials and
releasing classified documents so he's
been holed up in the Ecuadorian Embassy
in London now for years and apparently
these meetings happened in the
Ecuadorian Embassy this raises a few
questions
one why was Paul Manafort why would he
have met with Julian Assange well he
could have met what
was helping out viktor yanukovych who
was the pro-russian a head of ukraine
when he was lobbying for him i suppose
he could have done that WikiLeaks has a
tight relationship with Russia why would
he have met with him when he's just
about to take the helm of the Trump
campaign obviously the Democrats are
saying he met with him to ensure the
release of these emails to collude with
the Russians whatever you want to say my
question is why are we only learning
about this now why are we only learning
now in 2018 no almost 2019 that the head
of the Trump campaign around the time
that he was named the head of the Trump
campaign walked into the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London one of the most highly
surveilled places in the entire world
because everyone want to make she wants
to make sure that Julian Assange doesn't
make a break for it
they've got all these eyeballs on this
embassy and he just walks in and there's
no record of Paul Manafort ever even
being there Paul Manafort is not a low
profile guy it's not like Donald Trump
dug him out of obscurity Paul Manafort
has been a major Republican operative
for decades since the the 80s at least
and maybe the 70s so what are the odds
that he just walks into the embassy and
there's no record of it the the
Ecuadorian embassy has no formal record
of Paul Mann afford ever having been
there oh okay I know I I suppose I could
understand that a guy with the political
pull of Paul Manafort and an embassy
that would house Julian Assange maybe
might be a little axe with their
record-keeping might be willing to hide
certain things but how could this not
leak how would we not know about this
until just now it seems a little dodgy
I'm just a little bit skeptical of it
and it's not just because I want to
defend Paul Manafort ID or that I want
to defend Donald Trump it's just the
timing is a little weird and the facts
are a little dodgy they won't give us
the sources and the Guardian is already
backing off the story that this is the
part that really makes me question so
they put it up on their website this
morning and then one hour later they
they start to back off of it so the
initial headline on the Guardian was
manna fort held secret talks with
Assange in Ecuadorian embassy the new
headline an hour
later hour and ten minutes later nana
fort held secret talks with Assange in
Ecuadorian embassy sources say okay now
John Nolte our former colleague at the
Daily wire great writer he his twitter
name is sources say is greek for fake
news because they always do that new
york times does the CNN they say sources
say and then they spout off whatever
political nonsense is advantageous to
their side so that's one major change
another change is the initial article
read quote it is unclear why manna fort
wanted to see Assange and what was
discussed the new version reads it is
unclear why manna fort would have wanted
to see Assange and what was discussed
you see there was a switch into the
conditional initially they were using
very plain language that the new version
goes into the conditional hypothetically
if he would have done this why would he
have done that so the original says but
the last meaning is likely to come under
scrutiny and could interest robert
muller the special prosecutor the new
version but the last apparent meeting is
likely to come under scrutiny now why
are they doing this The Guardian is
doing this to save their rear ends
because now you've got a Paul Manafort
going after them you've got Julian
Assange going after them they are all
saying this is 100% fake news a and it
actually goes on and on in the original
version of the article they say
according to two sources manna fort
returned to the Embassy in 2015 now in
the new version it says according to
these sources manna fort returned to the
embassy in 2015 to these sources well
why why is the changer there now new
sources in there or there are fewer
sources or the sources of little dodgy
er I don't know initially the article
read why manna fort sought out Assange
in 2013 is unclear now it says why manna
fort might have sought out Assange in
2013 is unclear now all of this this
might this would this could this should
it sounds more like they're writing a
hypothetical fiction now then that
they're writing a reality you know if I
had some ham I could make a ham sandwich
if I had some bread it doesn't matter
how many hypotheticals we have what are
the facts this the Guardian knew this
was an explosive story they
should have gotten their facts dead
right dot there dot there T's and cross
their eyes before they publish this if
they're backing off of this now it's
it's a little doubtful to me how how
accurate it could be now why would we
why would the Guardian run this who are
the sources I don't know I mean we know
that we have had some pretty dodgy
characters from the whole beginning of
this Russian collusion story why are we
even talking about Russian collusion
we're talking about Russian collusion
because during the presidential campaign
we know the FBI was spying on the Trump
campaign we know that there was the
steal dossier that that document that
was used to launch investigations which
we now know was paid for was funded by
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats you've
got characters in the government working
on these things characters outside of
the government working on Democrat
politics so much of it seemed contrived
and so much of it seemed falsely faulty
rather how do we know whether the or the
Guardian article is real or not how do
we know whether the sources are reliable
or not the whole Russia investigation is
based on misinformation and faulty
stories just remember that steel dossier
the beginning of all of this the the you
know it had the the yeren tape the
alleged urine tape was was written about
in this so foreign policy analysts went
over there was a long spread in Newsweek
of all places that showed a number of
inconsistencies in that steel dossier
just to go over a few of them the steel
dossier alleged the Russian regime has
been cultivating supporting and
assisting Trump for at least five years
that claim seems the most preposterous
who five years ago would have thought
that Donald Trump would become president
he's a guy who'd been bloviating about
possibly running for president since the
eighties nobody took it seriously he
never did it he was he was had other
interests the political analysts didn't
take it seriously so that must mean that
Vladimir Putin is a psychic he could
read Trump's mind to knew he was going
to run and knew that the American people
would elect him that part just not not
credible at all another claim in the
steel dossier quote so far Trump has
declined
sweetheart real-estate business deals
offered to him in Russia we know this
isn't true because we know he was going
after sweetheart real estate deals in
Russia this is they can't have it both
ways the left can't have it that Donald
Trump is corrupt and he's using his
influence to try to get sweetheart deals
and to further enrich himself and that
he hasn't done that at all we know that
after the Miss Universe pageant in
Russia he was meeting with Russians to
try to get deals we know that he tried
in 2013 to get a Trump Hotel in Russia
so we know that that part of the steel
dossier is false it goes on it says
quote he and his inner circle have
accepted a regular flow of intelligence
from the Kremlin including on democratic
and other rivals okay that's it so these
things all sound plausible until you
scratch just below the surface if he is
regularly receiving a flow of
intelligence during the campaign why
didn't he use any of it the during the
campaign his main tools were saying mean
things about illegal aliens wearing
cheap hats and calling Hillary crooked
all of which I support all I'm all for
that but he didn't leak any shocking
information there's no evidence that he
got any any flows of intelligence what
else
obviously there was the the urine
alleged urine tape which we don't
believe because Donald Trump is a germ
freak he's a parent germaphobe and also
if he knew that they had some video like
that on him don't don't you think he
might have considered not running for
president isn't that just a ticking time
bomb yeah of course now it goes on
further in the steel dossier they say
that there's another dossier of
compromising material on Hillary Clinton
that was collected by the Russian
intelligence services over many years
and but it was not distributed abroad
including to Donald Trump okay also
totally believable Hillary Clinton
mishandled federal records we know she
was regularly communicating on unsecured
devices she had her own private email
server at home okay I totally believe
that they're collecting intel on her but
that line in the steel dossier
contradicts the earlier line on the
first hand were being told that Donald
Trump has regularly received
intelligence on all of his Democrat
opponents like Hillary then we're being
told he hasn't received intelligence on
Hillary that's a contradiction just
within the steel dossier which is it
we're then told later in the steel
dossier the dossier is controlled by
Kremlin spokesman Dmitry Peskov on
Putin's orders why on earth would a
spokesman be the one to to handle the
dossier and Hillary Clinton why would it
be I've worked as a spokesman for
politicians I've worked as a press
secretary that isn't the sort of thing
that you do when you're a press
secretary you smile on camera and you
communicate to the public what the
politician is thinking or doing when
you're a spy that's when you control
dossiers and you control a surveillance
on other people also it was pointed out
by Russian speakers when the steel
dossier came out that the syntax in many
places doesn't look like it was written
by a native English speaker might have
been written by a Russian and finally
we're told that in in the steel dossier
quote the existence of a Russian dossier
or complement on Hillary Clinton is
confirmed by source B and was collected
by Department K of the FSB for many
years now if you or I are reading that
it would be gibberish to us right it's
just it would be like reading Russian or
reading Greek or something we just don't
know
but what foreign policy analysts have
pointed out is that that department
Directorate k does not do intelligence
on foreign leaders there are other
departments that do that SVR foxy other
other departments that you or I have
never heard of but Directorate K doesn't
do that so how did all of this get in
there one of the suggestions is that the
steel dossier was actually Russian
misinformation so it was fed with false
information from Russians to further
complicate the American political system
and throw it into turmoil my question
the reason I just went through all of
that steel dossier stuff is how do we
know that's not what's happening with
this Guardian article how do we know
that we're not getting more Russian
misinformation the Russians have have
dealt and misinformation forever for
eternity and obviously during the Cold
War that was their specialty how do we
know that that's not what we're getting
who know what does Bob Mulder know is
this really what he knows or is is there
something else that we haven't heard of
yet is this being cooked up by bad
actors I'm not saying it look I'm not
saying I'm gonna believe Bob Muller a
rather Paul Manafort just because he
says so I'm not saying I'm gonna believe
Julian Assange just because he says so
I'm not I'm not saying that I'm just
going to believe Donald Trump just
because he says so or likewise Bob
Muller or Peter's struck or any of the
other people working on the admirer
investigation but we've got to parse
this out we've got a lot of people with
a lot of interests here trying to cover
up a lot of different things so which is
I don't know we know also today that
Muller is not only pressuring Paul
Manafort we know that he's pressuring
Jerome Corsi you might know Jerome Corsi
he I've followed him for a number of
years he's a conservative writer kind of
a conspiracy theorist type he says a lot
of kooky things so some people
completely write him off it's worth
noting he the guy does have a PhD in
political science from Harvard so you
can't write him off entirely he's not
you know he is a guy who is who has at
least studied political science
political philosophy at serious places
Jerome Corsi now expects to be indicted
and he has apparently rejected a plea
deal this is just a few weeks ago Jerome
Corsi went on television he said Muller
is going to indict me soon here's Jerome
Corsi I got served a subpoena on August
28th at my home two FBI agents show up
unannounced and did not talk to the FBI
cause my wife was pretty startled and we
began a series of discussions with them
that have gone on for two months and at
the end of that two months even though I
did everything I could to cooperate the
entire negotiations discussions have
just blown up and now I fully anticipate
that the next few days I will be
indicted by Muller for some form or
other of giving false information to the
Special Counsel or to one of the other
grand jury or however they want to do
the
indictment but I'm gonna be criminally
charged well he predicted it and it sure
looks like things are going that way now
we're we've learned that Jerome Corsi
who you know he's a conservative media
type he's written some books he I think
he was on Infowars
when he was going a little further out
so he's selling selling vitamins you
know and talking about the gay frogs no
I don't think he was do I think Alex
Jones was doing that he now expects to
be criminally charged and he's rejected
a plea deal now what is the plea deal
about what is he going to be charged
with threat this entire Muller
investigation they haven't gotten
anybody for any actual crime related to
the Trump campaign they haven't gotten
anybody for any actual crime related to
working with Russians or getting
information or spying on Hillary or
whatever they haven't they haven't
gotten them for that they've only gotten
them for procedural crimes for lying to
the FBI or perjuring themselves or not
telling the whole truth and of course
the old-line in DC is you could indict a
ham sandwich
especially on a procedural sort of crime
so what what is the perjury
did he perjure himself the issue with
jerome corsi
is jerome corsi predicted that wikileaks
had john podesta emails a week before
they were released he predicted that
they had them and then a week later
WikiLeaks releases them and now Muller
is looking and saying how did you know
that jerome corsi is saying was a lucky
guess
obviously Muller thinks that he was
tipped off by somebody that he was in
contact with somebody at WikiLeaks who
knows
was it a lucky guess I don't know it's
hard to imagine that it's not totally
out of the realm of possibility because
John Podesta was running Hillary
Clinton's campaign so I suppose it's not
saying it's 100% not true but that's not
even the question the question on
perjury is did he intentionally
willfully lie to the investigators or
did he just leave something out did he
omit something
Muller is now pressuring Jerome Corsi to
plead guilty to one count of perjury and
how will this relate I don't know this
could relate to WikiLeaks this could
relate to Roger stone who said that he
had had information from WikiLeaks
and then later said he didn't have
direct information was through an
intermediary who knows course he is
sticking to his story that he forgot
certain things but did not willfully lie
to the investigators I almost am tempted
to believe him here because if he enters
into a plea deal and says I lied on one
count and maybe it could be reduced or
maybe this or I could be pardoned or I
won't be in jail very long or whatever
that seems preferable to them throwing
the book at Corsi but what Jerome Corsi
is saying is I would rather rot away in
prison then cop to something that I did
not do that I'm not I did not lie I'm
not gonna say that I lied just because
Bob Muller wants me to I'm not gonna
spout a storyline that the special
counsel is trying to build if it's not
true and that is where Donald Trump
comes in because you see this building
over time Bernard Kerik the former
police commissioner in New York
suggested this in some tweets yesterday
some on the right are now saying that
the special counsel has a storyline they
have a narrative of Trump collusion and
nefarious activities that they are going
to build and they are gonna force people
to say that it's true even if it's not
true Donald Trump he tweeted out in his
typical subdued way quote the phoney
witch hunt continues
but Muller and his gang of angry Dems
are only looking at one side not the
other wait until it comes out how
horribly and viciously they are treating
people ruining lives for them refusing
to lie Muller is a conflicted prosecutor
gone rogue
the fake news media builds Bob Muller up
as a saint when in actuality he's the
exact opposite he's doing tremendous
damage to our criminal justice system
where he is only looking at one side and
not the other heroes will come of this
and it won't be Muller in his terrible
gang of angry Democrats it goes on don't
worry it's not there's a three tweet
tweet he goes on he says look at their
past look where they come from the now
30 million dollar witch-hunt
and they've got nothing but ruined lives
where is the server where's the Hillary
email server good point let these
terrible people go back to the Clinton
Foundation and Justice Department he
makes a good point Donald Trump makes a
good point
why where are the investigations into
Hillary where are where are all where is
the the prosecution where are the
investigations into Democrats
why was the Muller investigation stacked
with so many anti Trump never Trump
operatives why was it stacked with
somebody Peter struck who said in a text
message to his lover I will use the
force of the FBI to prevent Donald Trump
from being president why why would that
is a little weird it's a little weird
that it's dragged on like this and
they've got nothing thus far they've
come up with nothing so what are we to
make with all of it we know that Paul
man affords dodgy we know that WikiLeaks
is dodgy we know that the FBI and
officials who were involved in the
Muller investigation are dodgy the
investigation itself is dodgy and Donald
Trump loved him to death but you know is
it occasionally can be a little bit
dodgy or you can dodge questions so you
can now massage that we know that there
are a lot of people here and we can't
take any of them at their word that's
fine put not your trust in Princes I
don't put my faith in princes but just
pull out of the details I wanted to give
you the details here because you're
gonna hear narratives being spun on
constantly you're going to hear all of
these things in the mainstream media and
because you don't know that they're
expecting you not to know the details so
that they can spin their yarn but you
need to know the details to know that
that's not true oh that's not true but
now that you know the details zoom out
what are we looking we're looking at
Paul Manafort
a political operative is rotting away in
solitary confinement and the question I
got to ask you is would he be there if
Donald Trump were not elected president
if he had never worked for Donald Trump
would he be there let's say he were just
lobbying for Ukraine doing his
activities you know kind of being a
Republican operative would he be I know
I know he's in jail for other crimes
I know it's tax evasion or this or that
right would
he'd be in prison if he had not
committed the unforgivable sin of
helping Donald Trump become president of
course not Bill Clinton commits perjury
he commits perjury while he's president
gets off scot-free no problem
Hillary Clinton improperly handles
federal records she then destroys those
federal records why because she was
accepting bribes while she was in office
tens of millions of dollars from the
Saudi government to use just one foreign
regime that's that's in the news is
selling our uranium to Russian interests
approving the sale in exchange for
apparently some money Oh what happens to
her that's no problem but Paul Manafort
has the audacity to work for Trump he's
gonna rot in prison what crime is Donald
Trump being accused of can you name one
crime no of course not they accuse him
of collusion because they don't have a
crime that they can name and collusion
is not a crime there is no law against
collusion and by the way if if there
were a law against collusion Hillary
Clinton would be a culpable of it this
whole thing was kicked off by a steel
dossier that was funded by Hillary
Clinton and the Democrats they were the
ones where did the information from the
steel dasya came from it came from the
Russians it had to come from the
Russians they're the only ones with the
information so we we know for a fact
that Hillary Clinton paid with her money
through various intermediaries but from
the campaign and the DNC paid for this
information colluded with the Russians
did exactly what Donald Trump is being
accused of doing
why is there no investigation into her
why are they dogging these Republicans I
don't know it seems that there's a lot
else at stake what is this really about
is this about the Donald Trump campaign
no way it stinks to high heaven we will
have to get to more of that but we can't
get to it now because we've got vegans
to talk about and have vegans were in
everything we've got this awful woman
who is ruining her child's life by
trying to castrate him and tonight you
should come out to Florida State
University I'm gonna be at FSU tonight
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern for the latest stop
on my yafnaf fa on campus tour
snowflakes obviously will be melting
everywhere so get your tumbler
ready we will be discussing why I'm on
the wrong side of history class it
should be a lot of fun it will cause us
a lot of cons maybe the maybe the
professor's will come out and protest me
this time
maybe the gender studies sociology
professors will come out and march on my
speech we'll see we'll see what happens
show up tonight it's gonna be a lot of
fun 6:00 p.m. Eastern at FSU if you are
on daily wire.com thank you very much
you help keep the lights on even in this
hotel room
you keep coffe fa and mic up if you're
not go to daily wire.com ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the end work leave and
show you get to mention puro show you
have to ask questions in the mailbag you
get a lot of stuff none of that matters
the leftist here's tumblr matters did
you go to your left-wing relatives for
Thanksgiving and not bring the tumblr
well no you you didn't because you would
have drowned and you wouldn't be
watching this show right now make sure
that you don't do this at Christmas that
would be especially with the
temperatures getting lower and lower
the leftist tears will freeze you'll get
leftist hail storms it can really be
dangerous knock you on the head don't do
that go to daily wire calm we will be
right back
now enough about all of this
international espionage
you know presidential advisors going to
jail major powers enough of that that
doesn't matter what we need to talk
about is how vegans ruin everything they
ruin everything
there was a video there were some nice
British people just trying to enjoy a
steak meal maybe some delicious veal
some you know nice little delicious baby
baby baby veal and a bunch of vegans
stormed in and hilariously tried to ruin
their dinner here they are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no excuse for a delicious foie
gras on cheeseburgers there's no there's
no substitute it's what you mean there's
nothing so mmm
nothing so delicious I won't out a
friend of mine of a member of Congress
who I was talking about this issue one
time with that person and I said did you
ever see that movie meat from the 1970s
and that this person turned to me said
oh yeah I saw this whole movie about how
awful the meat industry is gosh I left
there just hankering for a porterhouse
mmm couldn't wait licking my chops in
the movie theater these lunatics were
coming in there and the reason I bring
it up i via you know these vegetarian
types are always a little excitable but
the reason I bring it up is to show the
moral idiocy and the moral mistakes that
can come when you hone in on one very
minor aspect of the human life and you
make an idol out of that you make that
your God you you turn into a moral idiot
you make a lot of errors this group is
called direct action everywhere they
come and I guess they're going in
everywhere better not come to my steak
house they go into this steak house in
Britain and the normal patrons who are
just trying to enjoy their meal you
couldn't see it in the video but later
on they start mooing that's like you
know food it's not food it's murder its
violence and you just hear the patrons
go Moo Moo so that was pretty funny but
veganism is on the rise and it's on the
rise because this country is morally
very confused right now there is one one
survey that showed that since 2014 so
we're joining the last four years
veganism has increased in the United
States by 500%
I didn't believe this until I recently
was having lunch with some friends of
mine and they're vegan and they brought
me to a vegan restaurant and I paid $30
for a mushroom and I was very angry and
I ate beet ketchup and not real kid I
guess I guess some presume reason real
ketchup is not
for vegans so it's made of beets and
it's not ketchup and it doesn't taste
anything like ketchup so this is a moral
idiocy I don't mean that my friends are
moral idiots but in this regard that
they're missing the forest for the trees
this is emblematic I find of a lot of a
lot of vegans maybe all the vegans seem
to care more about animals than people
we talked about this last week
how many vegans do you know who are
pro-life probably not many I know a lot
of vegans who are pro-abortion
pro-choice and yet they freak out if you
eat an oyster
if you meet it and the oysters matter
we'll get to that in a second but plenty
of immoral people can be vegetarians a
Hitler was a vegetarian and Hitler loved
dogs he really I don't use this just an
is it isn't he know he'll er drank water
and Hillary Clinton drinks water and
therefore she's terrible but I am
pointing out Hitler who is rightly
considered one of the most evil figures
in history certainly in modern history
did have this moral stance of being a
vegetarian and he loved animals
some people are shocked by this they say
oh my gosh can you imagine oh it makes
perfect sense to me he didn't he didn't
really like humans very much but he
certainly liked animals he mistook what
matters in the in the order of life and
in the natural order these vegans
believe that a little chicken is more
morally valuable than a human baby why
is this this leads even to certain
questions I I hope that we get for the
vegan movement what we have gotten from
LGBT and feminism and transgenderism
that is an essential conflict that
starts to hit them because in feminism
you have the deconstruction of gender
the breaking down of the gender
categories ultimately this leads to the
denial that gender exists at all this
leads to transgenderism and ultimately
the undercutting of feminism I wonder if
we'll see the same thing with veganism
because what we're told by veganism is
it's not just enough not to eat meat or
not just enough not to eat you know baby
seals and dolphins or something or not
just enough not to eat
but you can't even eat animal products
you can't eat fish you can't eat milk
you can't eat cheese you can't eat eggs
you can't eat things that come from
animals why because then the animals
have to produce them and they're
suffering and it isn't good and it
encourages more farming of animals okay
so that's taken it to another extreme
there was an article in The Huffington
Post recently which said that VA vegans
are not allowed to eat oysters
what's an oyster an oyster is just a
little bit of goop that you put some
sauce on sometimes and and slurp down at
a bar while you're having a martini
that's what an oyster is doesn't have a
nervous system it in almost no way
resembles an animal so some vegans have
said well doesn't even have a central
nervous system I'm not doesn't really
matter now vegans are saying you can't
eat that either it it feels pain and is
in its own way there's no scientific
basis for this oysters of course don't
feel pain but what they're saying is how
dare you be so presumptuous as to impose
your categories of pain on the little
oyster this is exactly what happened
with the transgender movement and
feminism they said how dare you impose
your categories of what is a woman or
what isn't a woman on humanity don't you
dare suggest that that men can't have a
uterus some men have a uterus to quote
Planned Parenthood so is the same thing
you're seeing this in veganism how dare
you impose your Western science on the
oyster the oyster might feel pain we
just don't know well where does that end
does that just end with oysters what
about scallops okay maybe scallops too
or mussels or clams what about what
about a carrot a carrot doesn't feel
pain a carrots not conscious yeah write
them on a stirs not conscious certainly
not conscious not sentient are you
kidding me what about a Venus flytrap
those are those are plants rather the
plant closes its its little flaps and
eats flies it's a carnivorous plant can
we eat the venus flytrap is that not
sentient it reacts to external stimuli
stimula yeah stimuli sorry it reacts to
them but but many plants react to
external stimuli its reactive or how who
are you to say that it doesn't feel pain
where does this end why are you imposing
your category and saying that animals
lives matter but plants lives don't
matter now it will get to this point
there will be people who do this they
won't last very long because they'll
starve to death but at a certain point
we have to consume things that live we
can't just eat rocks this is what the
devil tempted Christ are doing the
wilderness he said turn that rock into
bread said I'm not going to do that
that's a fantasy that's ridiculous
so where does that where is that going
to go from there
obviously what they're going to be
following that idea to its logical
conclusion but the idea premises
themselves are not logical the idea that
we should exalt the oyster over the
human being humans are more important we
have more dignity we are conscious we
have dominion over the land and over the
sea that is the reality of it and the
denial of that reality by the vegan
movement and vegetarianism is plausible
at a little bit it's plausible when you
eat less red meat it's plausible even
when you give up cheese like a dummy I
don't know why you would ever give up
cheese but when you take it to its
logical conclusion it's not plausible
and that's fine by me they're going to
look even more ridiculous than they do
when they interrupt those Brits eating
mutton or whatever British people eat in
steak houses in a school in Virginia in
Fairfax there is some good news I was so
excited when I saw this story today the
news was that the school is making the
students read the Pledge of Allegiance
oh that's good oh I'm plea I'm very
pleased to see that really in a lot of
places now you don't have to say the
Pledge of Allegiance when I grew up you
said the Pledge of Allegiance now it
even you know even in events I'd go to
dinner as you recite the Pledge of
Allegiance
now people don't really have to do it so
so that's that's a good sign the bad
sign is the school is having them recite
the Pledge of Allegiance in Spanish this
is a pretty bad idea so they started
doing it they did this for I think one
day and the parents were so rightly
outraged by it that the principal came
in and canceled it now one mother who
supported it said quote they had a
native Spanish speaker read at Tuesday
end of school day Tuesday afternoon the
principal comes on and says he was sorry
he is sorry didn't want to be offensive
they canceled the program it was my
understanding it would be Spanish French
and German
I think there's 80 or 90 different
languages at this school and I thought
that would be a cool thing okay first of
all lady there aren't 80 languages at
your school they aren't certainly there
aren't 80 being taught and there are an
80 being spoken they're trying to count
little nothing dialects or something and
there and I think they're just making
that out so there are in 80 or 90
different languages and also stop
pretending that this is about French and
German they didn't they didn't decide to
institute the reading of the Pledge of
Allegiance in Spanish so that we could
practice our French or our German that
did not happen at all in the school
admits it as much the school said that
they were trying to promote engagement
and inclusion quote this is a statement
from the school a school administrator
suggested students lead the Pledge in
Spanish to promote engagement and
inclusion administrators believed this
was an opportunity for other voices and
languages to be heard and to recognize
the school diversity are they
recognizing the diversity of all those
French immigrants at the school how
about all those German immigrants who
finally made it over to recognize their
diversity of course not this is about
Spanish and we've seen this trend for
years now when you call up customer
service they say press 1 for English or
press 1 for Spanish or whatever because
it has not been encouraged for people to
assimilate into the United States this
is a big problem so they say ok we're
going to say the Pledge of Allegiance in
Spanish why the United States is not a
Spanish country the United States does
not speak Spanish or the Declaration of
Independence was not written in Spanish
the Constitution was not written in
Spanish our founding fathers didn't
speak Spanish I'm all for learning
different languages I speak multiple
languages I like it I I read the Italian
newspaper frequently I yeah I'm all for
it I don't think we should recite the
Pledge of Allegiance in Italian they the
point of the Pledge of Allegiance is to
come together as a country and say I
respect this country I pledge my
allegiance to this country we are one
nation indivisible what these people
want to do is divide it and it's because
of such a perverse sense of inclusion
this
is what another person said another
mother quote it's inclusive it's making
them proud of their heritage and their
ethnicity so I was surprised that
instead of continuing it there was a
nixing and an apology didn't seem right
to me
it's not inclusive it's exclusive when
you have people who come people come to
this country of the Americans or they
should and if they don't want to be
Americans they shouldn't come so they
come to this country to escape whatever
awful place they were living in before
and they make it here they should
encourage them to be Americans we should
not exclude them or make them different
or make them other by encouraging them
to speak the language that we don't
speak here that's a very bad idea it's
making them proud of their heritage in
their ethnicity it's fine to take some
some enjoyment in your heritage I do
that you know I'm Italian so I wear a
wear a crucifix no I'm Catholic and I
wear a crucifix and I'm Italian so I
wear a gold chain I you know I it's nice
to enjoy that I eat a lot of monolith
and a lot of cannoli and things like
that okay that's great but I'm not proud
I don't walk around saying I'm an
Italian I don't I don't walk around
waving the Italian flag of course not
I'm an American I'm as American as apple
pie a little swarthy apple pie but you
know a little burnt a little crispy
apple pie and that's how people who come
to this country should be brought in -
you shouldn't be pratt but you're gonna
be exactly proud of your heritage and
ethnicity you left that you left that
behind to come to America what
translation I wonder of the Pledge were
they using in Spanish which version they
don't have a translation because the
pledge is written to pledge allegiance
to the United States a really bad idea
not good for the immigrants who come
here if they're encouraged not to learn
English very well or to speak Spanish it
it will hurt them in their careers
certainly and we'll make them other it
will make them a second class and we're
here to be Americans
if you can't pledge allegiance under one
language then you're not pledging
allegiance to your country at all okay
that's our show I have got to go give
this speech in FSU it's gonna be a lot
of fun if you're in Tallahassee come on
out the topic we'll be talking a little
bit about American history a lot about
it tonight we'll have to get to the this
awful mother in Texas who's forcing her
son to be pretending to be a woman who
is trying to castrate him
this woman obviously should be in jail
or in a mental institution we'll get to
that tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Knowles oh is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018